لا علاج له مميت خطير وسريع الانتشار
نتحدث هنا عن فيروس الذي يثير انتشاره
حاله من الفزع عالميا فهو يتسبب بحمى
نزفيه شديده العدوى بحسب مراكز السيطره
على الامراض الامريكيه
وهو من عائله فيروس ايبولا وكلاهما لديه
القدره على التسبب في معدلات وفيات عاليه
بين المصابين الصحه العالميه قالت ان
معدلات الوفيات بين مصابين بفيروس ماربورغ
تتراوح بين 24 الى 88% وفقا لحالات
الانتشار السابقه وتعرف العلماء لاول مره
على هذا الفيروس عام 67 عندما انتشر بين
عمال المختبرات في ماربورج وفرانكفورت
بالمانيا وفي بلغراد اثناء اجراء البحوث
على حيوانات تم استيرادها من اوغندا
ورغم ان هذا الفيروس لا ينتقل عبر الهواء
فانه ينتشر بسرعه من خلال الاتصال المباشر
بين البشر خاصه المرتبطين بالسوائل مثل
الدم او اللعاب او البول ويمكن حتى لجثث
المصابين ان تبقى معديه عند الدفن ووفقا
لمنظمه الصحه العالميه تقدر فتره الحضانه
للاصابه بالفيروس بين ثلاثه الى تسعه ايام
وتبدا اعراضه بالاصابه بالصداع حاد ووعكه
شديده والام عضليه وتشمل ايضا حمى شديده
وايضا وهن تدريجي وسريع اسهال حاد والم في
البطن وغثيان وتقيؤ يمكن ان يدوم اسبوعا
استمرار الاصابه تؤدي الى اصابه الجهاز
العصبي في الحالات المميته تحدث الوفاه في
اليوم الثامن او التاسع بعد الاصابه
ويرى معظم المختصين ان الوقايه بشكل عام
من الحمى النزفيه المرتبطه بالفيروسات مثل
مار برج او ايبولا قد تكون امرا صعبا اذا
كنت تعيش في مناطق تنتشر فيها هذه الامراض
او تسافر اليها وعليك استخدام وسائل
الوقايه عند التعامل مع اي من سوائل الجسم
بارتداء قفازات وواقيات العين والوجه كما
يجب تجنب الحشرات خاصه البعوض
والجراد وعليك ارتداء السراويل الطويله
والاكمام الطويله واستخدام وسائل الحمايه
من البعوض كما عليك ايضا ابعاد القوارض عن
منزلك بوضع القمامه في حاويات مضاده
للقوارض والتخلص من النفايات بانتظام
والحرص على ان يكون للابواب والنوافذ
واقيات للحشرات
واذا كانت الوقايه صعبه فالعلاج لم يعتمد
بعد ويتلقى المصابون الرعايه الداعمه
وعلاجات للمضاعفات والجفاف تعمل على تحسين
معدلات البقاء على قيد الحياه وفق منظمه
الصحه العالميه وينصح بعض خبراء الصحه
العامه باستخدام الادويه المستخدمه في
العلاج من الاصابه بالايبولا ولكن حتى
الان لم تثبت التجارب السريريه نجاعه
الامر